oh my god it came out the back it came
out the back
put the cut side down
[Music]
it's a buttercream okay okay it's like a
big bagel
it just smeared like a big bag there's
no hole in the middle
i mean it's it's like a big what's a
bagel without a hole a bialy what is it
i don't know right a b ollie okay so now
what do we do we do
all the other times pick up the other
one okay and then
turn it over put the cut side put the
cut side down
okay right sure sure
i'm like is this the cut side holes
doing great good joe's doing great
okay look at joel doing great you got it
all in there
what's next yeah on top and then yeah
you put some buttercream on top
okay get it on there do we do the side
as well obviously you can do the sides
okay do the side
i i feel like this demo was doomed
before it even started oh my god it came
out the back it came out the back
i swear that never happened
okay magic okay and
and i'm done i don't know about you guys
great oh that was good
it's really cool i know what okay do you
want blue or orange blue
blue okay i'll take orange i'm still
over here making this perfect then
you can uh you can do this right go all
the way around oh my god do you listen
to music while you do this i would have
to
yeah okay oh wait i thought you were
doing little oh
shoot wait a minute okay okay okay
you're the chef chef you do it
everything's gonna be great it's
great it's great um and then
yeah you can squirt some
oh well i know one i know one thing this
is this is called piping isn't it this
is called piping
this is called piping i want sprinkles
all right
then you can take all this stuff and you
can throw it
you can like i mean yeah go to town yes
get someone
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this was before we the producers didn't
even know this my kids have actually
been to your shop here and made cakes
and brought them home did they have fun
and i hated them because i ate it
they were good i loved it they loved it
i'm done
i wrote it all right carrie underwood
that's right that's great
oh oh no
so growing up in texas this is a real
thing i didn't know sushi even existed
like until i was like 18 like maybe 19.
um now it's one of my favorite foods i
love sushi and because i don't always
have time to grab sushi
today i'm bringing it to us from one of
my favorite
sushi spots here in la seriously they
know me by name everyone that works
there
please welcome koi executive chef rob
lucas thank you
so hello i'm so happy you're here
i'm gonna wrap it all up and eat it
tonight um so what are we making today
okay uh actually we're gonna do one of
your favorite dishes
on the menu very popular item uh
it's the crispy rice yes what we're
going to do is we're going to put
you put in the rice yeah go ahead and
put it in this uh frying pan which is
getting rid of that oil on it or is that
just chicken
no that's clarified butter oh or
whatever do these sesame oil is so good
for you
in a lot of ways that's why they say
open sesame we're putting all of this in
here
yeah that's true i read a book
okay so what's this this is smelt egg
it's like okay is that massage
okay do all of it all of it now this
gives you that crunch and the pop
sorry i don't know what that is for me
sorry um don't eat mine
you guys got everything mixed okay i
think so
go ahead and start mixing it okay
i think you have a spatula wait this is
just going to be a minute
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
how much you're looking good
that looks so good that looks really
good can i just eat this
i always feel like okay i think it looks
pretty good
you got sticks yeah i think i'm nailing
it guys okay so then do we flip now
do we flip and don't fail okay yeah can
i flip
yeah okay be careful that's hot okay i'm
okay with hats i want to flip it
i'm used to it i'm used to having a
dealing with hot rob
every day in the mirror every day in the
mirror
okay okay did y'all flip yours
is here for the buffet it's very good i
love it i love it fine i want to eat my
own
that was awesome i think i did
everything yeah i think i think you guys
did really good i like to uh
okay what is this is this ponzu oh
that's just
soy soy oh okay nevermind i'm gonna do
it anyway i like lemonade
i love ya'll i should have brought
she said as if she had never had it
before
as if i did anything as if you did
anything so good
so amazing and new
earlier you said you were skeptical
about l.a pizza neil so let's we're
going to turn this around
bring it on there we're going to take us
around don't you doubt it
some about it on a pizza i don't know
about that oh he
i'm in it i'm all about it it's so solid
where do we start okay so my favorite
part about making pizza is stretching
the dough
yeah i kind of go with like the street
terminology of stretching the dough
right okay so we want to do is we want
to create a base
just a little circle make sure you got
your circle neal we know that you know
how to do this so we're going to let you
get at it
ladies ladies we're going to show neil
that we know what's up
now we're going to stretch it here in
the bottom me neither so now you're
going to put the dough down
down now we're going to pat down right
down yeah and
oscillating moment here we go yeah
oh there she's getting the and then what
we do is we bring it up top here
oh gosh and you just have to kind of
like you know knead it oh like what
toss the dough it's all in the wrist
neil's got it oh
you know
[Applause]
doughboy fast enough he looks like this
well this is a dough girl
so the dough girl spins it like this
it's all centrifugal force
there you go wait for it
right right right so now that we've
already stretched our dough
oh yeah we've totally mastered that now
we're gonna we're gonna put it on our
pan here that was okay so let's put our
dough on our patches okay
all right done the pan then we're gonna
get our sauce we gotta make it saucy
right
yes we're gonna get our marinara here
right here i'm gonna pour it there
we go i'll give you a little marinara
guys and we just kind and he's kind of
just you know in a circle
and new york style pizza is very
everything is uh minimal you know less
okay so it's not like texas okay no no
yeah that's right so then we're gonna go
we have all these grapes
yeah we have all these great ingredients
everything's fresh in our garden i got
dough girl we have vegan meats that are
amazing
we can start with either vegan cheese
i'm a plant-based eater so i'm gonna go
with the vegan cheese
i'm a cheese eater you can be anything
i could be anything i want my mama told
me mar what'd your mama tell you
my mama told me i could be anything i
wanted and look i believed her that's
right
we're gonna have to hire you about dough
girl okay i don't think you should but i
do like pizza
i'm not gonna lie i worked at papa
john's world
wow oh so kelly clarkson is a dough girl
i'm a dough girl i never mastered that
part i did the toppings
right right right okay so then we get
the toppings you see that that's how it
goes let me go around and check this is
actually like my favorite pizza
see what everybody got is going here
please let me oh okay i'm making jupiter
oh you got jupiter going
it's a jupiter red spot right there the
pepperoni the pepperoni jupiter's red
spot
that's all right jupiter you would make
an organized it's a new kind of pizza
for yourselves
i don't know what you might put on me
not to brag awesome okay now we're gonna
eat let's go
i'm gonna try that yeah all right let's
try it together okay we got to do it
i'm gonna try this pizza i'm busy with
jupiter here please
whatever you don't like fries i can't
stand your name all right
you get to try this oh my god okay let
me know we have to do a pizza
cheers oh pizza cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i hear you're making a special dish
though this thanksgiving yes
oh my god okay so i just learned well
not just
i've been learning how to cook because i
don't know i just really wanted to be
like that girl just like cooking
listening to music like i don't even
care
messy fun way i love people who cook
like this
[Music]
just get in there drive stream on how to
cook so that's the goal
oh okay thank you kevin well thank you
very much kevin
what's up don't look at it i'm not done
totally not
so i'm learning how to cook
this is mine i listen i listen to my
guests
thank you that's my water by the way all
right
i'm really happy this is going so well
so what is it lasagna soup
it's lasagna lasagna i've never heard of
lasagna soup
it's lasagna made into a soup did you
okay wait but
wait so can i look at it now can we yes
okay
did you just play a game of mad libs and
we're like
so it's from last night and i don't know
how they prepared it okay
it used to be insane what happened to
you in the kitchen yeah
the dance moves i was in the kitchen i
may hear everything
that's really good but like imagine if
like what makes it soup
oh that's so this is called this is
called pasta
oh no it's because i do it wrong i love
you
so wait we did it wrong i do it i do it
incorrectly but that's what now makes it
my secret so it's supposed to be soup
but i always do it perfectly every
single time and it ends up like that
i don't know why i love you grace
you are officially my favorite sorry
[Music]
i've worked up quite an appetite from
laughing with america foreign
now it's time for food say hello to
ronnie woo
all right so your instagram page has
just as many shirtless pics as food pics
first of all please explain like why are
you wearing a shirt
where are the pigs by the way oh god
okay so wait we're making sushi tacos
which i'm in but how do we get started
okay
super super easy okay so america and
kelly you guys are gonna make the rice
i always say make rice in a rice cooker
done yep
just blinked and there's rice in a bowl
do you guys cook oh that smells like
don't ever cook oh i love to cook but
none of the ingredients that i use are
on the table
what do you cook with us butter lard
salt
that's in my pantry too very good all
right what's next
okay so you let that sit for a little
bit and then ty and start gonna make the
sauce okay
okay okay so we have some mayo in here
use light mayo vegan meal whatever kind
of meal you have on hand
regular mayo regular milk i'm the same
way regular meal all the way some soy
sauce
this is one of those really easy dump
recipes okay you just dump everything in
there
rice fine vinegar some sriracha you can
put as little or as much as you like
spicy i like stuff all right
i like spicy too but like i feel like i
sweat so much
it's true who cares just sweat it out
some toasted sesame oil from that warm
thanks
just give it a nice mix why
inconvenience your food with aesthetics
true okay
you're not starting real well yeah
america's destruction
it looks kind of clumpy come on tight oh
faster like back and forth your stir
game is
crap okay here we go here we go here we
go and this is i hear you like reading
places
you want like a book party this is
perfect for a book party
i want a book party yeah yeah i'll come
over and make this for you guys okay
yeah or you're like a date night or if
you know picky eaters in your family you
have a big family
yes you can literally have a little bit
of everything they all like something
different it's super fun
super fun right oh i feel you i know how
that is it doesn't create rage at all
which is good
yeah yeah yeah i don't know it's great
you're a funny girl
i'm just telling the truth
okay so we have the sauce well is your
sauce made titus yes oh looks good
it's very smooth mine is clumpy i am not
going to put no sriracha in my mail stay
on that side
you can have you can actually hide
america
we got the sriracha right okay so the
next part is the fun part
customization okay kelly yes we have
cute little
seaweed wraps it's all taking another
one gorgeous wrap multiple
yeah okay we're going to add a little
bit of wasabi okay just use your finger
just a big swipe down the middle so so
how much rice like if you're congested
just literally just put a ton
yes just literally put more in like it
doesn't even matter this much okay again
it's personal preference
okay then fill me up girl what's next
how are you doing down there
is it watery you know what is this there
a show called like the worst cooks in
america
[Laughter]
i think i ate some wasabi it's not
baking it was on your finger
i know guys good night or like go use
the restroom oh my god
that would burn really bad i'd be like
what is happening oh that's just wasabi
okay the one that you made is that okay
yeah
okay this way because i'm not doing it
i'm going to eat the one i made so are
you
putting that on yes so you want to put
this stuff on so choose whatever
toppings you want what all is it
i love sushi we have like shrimp we have
cooked salmon again you can use cooked
stuff raw stuff
salmon tuna cucumbers i'm gonna do
ginger
some albacore literally do whatever you
want yes
yes right you literally can put anything
you want you can let me put bam in here
or you shouldn't but you could no you
could it's like a thing
okay yeah totally okay i'm putting some
sauce on it like a lot because i'm
texting
yep um okay can i have some of that
sauce
i'm gonna eat it okay i'm gonna eat it
here we go oh my god
cheers cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
about his comedy chops but what you may
not know is that he
is also talented in the kitchen i am so
excited because he's going to show us
how to make his famous
egg salad sandwich eugene how did you
come up with the recipe
well exhale you know
uh some somebody actually said how how
would you like to i was asked once how
would you like to uh die
i said well i'd like to die in my sleep
in my bed
with a half-eaten egg salad sandwich on
my chest
wait are these eggs from your house
these these are my
chicken's eggs yes yes i have chickens
the small one they're from my silkies
because they're weird-looking we have
chickens in nashville it's better yolk
the yolk is much brighter the egg is
better
so i use a grinder grinder grated great
great reading right so you grate it down
okay and grate it down and please
okay watch your fingers know i have done
this
i uh had a summer job once when i was
working in a
fast food restaurant
slicing pickles and
um i looked in the pickles and i said
ooh what's that mushroom doing in the
pickles
no the key is and i gotta say this could
not be simpler
but it's all in the uh seasoning
really is what it's all about now some
people say how much salt do you use
i say oh about
about that much that much okay you just
eyeball it
i bought it eyeball it eyeball it now i
like to go
i like pepper a little heavier on the
peppers
i love peppers and i salt and pepper
before i
put in the mayo oh my god this looks
good
and and again for this amount of eggs
you say well how much
mayo do you put in i say well yeah
think of yourself at home very depressed
one night with a just a big
bucket of ice cream what would your
first
still like david and
mine is a lot more depressing
this is why you look fit eugene all
right yeah well
there we go all right well that's it
that's it pepper's got in my nose how do
you like yourself
i have a secret ingredient oh wait what
but
it's relish oh well my husband does
relish
some people do put relish yeah
it's not really the thing to do
shade shade but if it makes you happy
then
so where is the bread part where's the
bread
wait did you just eat it out of the bowl
there's no sandwich yet i have to find
out how everything's blending and this
is blending beautifully
but now are you going oh
oh these are carrots from our garden we
have a rooftop garden
you can come over and have some of my
carrots now i have some of this and
these are olives from my olive trees
bragger in canada that i keep in the
back of my car
[Laughter]
let's so go ahead pick the best bagel of
your cheese bagel is from my baking i'll
go play pan pan please
now try this yours yours
i'll try yours yeah don't touch that
gross relish one
how about that so then we eat it oh you
don't make a sandwich
wait for that okay
me neither
it
you is and i am so happy to meet you too
like congratulations first of all 100
you just turned 100 yeah that's
amazing yeah yeah
i'm gonna go okay okay i'm gonna start
look watch this out her first pupil was
sarah i'm getting it everywhere
is that okay oh no no you got you gotta
stir that first
i know oh you don't want me to put a
little bit of this oh no oh of course i
cook all the time
i am quite the baker yeah and then as
soon as that gets mixed up put in your
sour cream
okay okay okay right you meant to trade
off i thought you meant trade yeah i was
marjorie you've really got this kelly
you're doing a hell of a what a cook you
are
i'm nailing it yeah what a match all
right
all right i'm doing it i'm doing it a
little bit at a time people a little bit
at a time
is this like right joking i'm gonna
start licking my fingers too because
that's how i do in the kitchen
wait what oh oh marjorie i'll be well
you know you're way around the kitchen
though
yeah i can sing real pretty sometimes
yeah
okay yeah it's great it's going
everywhere yeah and then the rest of the
sour cream
and then that okay okay there you go and
then we're going to get started
what do you want us to do your shoes
she's going to screw that up let's move
over here
flowers yeah so when she does the batter
here's the brown sugar
right yeah you're going to add some
melted butter
some coconuts some what do i put this in
here right here i'll put this in there
everything goes into everything goes in
there yeah right it's supposed to be
melted butter
i know when you when you melt the mother
the day before
it doesn't she does what kelly doesn't
understand she's never melted butter
yeah right you got it there we go okay
we got our melted butter
see if you can spread that one i can
spread the okay yeah it's hard to spread
come on
you're slipping you're only 100 get to
work
[Laughter]
maybe if we put a little bit more a
little bit more in there
there we go yeah all right let's see oh
yeah now this way we do it on tv watch
we put it in the oven down here like
no no it's not and then it comes out
oh you got to put that on this no on
this one i'll put that in there i'll put
some on each one
okay there you go okay we gotta we got
to wrap it up i'm gonna have to come
down here
and look how it comes out right yeah
i'm very good okay you're just holding
it are you
uh
[Music]
i love spicy pork i love burritos if
only there was a better way to enjoy
both of them
ah enter my show my next guest has the
answers and
it all comes down to one secret
ingredient say hello to the chef behind
la's hottest gourmet korean mexican taco
truck
kogi roachoy
i'm so excited you're here so what are
we making
all right we're going to make the kogi
spicy pork burrito okay and
shout out to my brooklyn nine-nine
family stephanie we're going to add
these hot cheetos to it so this is for
them they love it so first thing we got
to do
hey guys we're going to cook right
i think so unless it's a joke you know
put a little bit of oil oil on it
and then we're going to toast the
tortilla first okay okay oh you just
touch it like that it's not hot on your
fingers oh no on this side
go ahead yeah okay i know how to do this
right you bam okay
okay okay yeah now let's do that on that
same area i want to show off throw your
meat and
same area put the oil and then your meat
and eggs eggs together
okay this okay more oil oh my gosh i'm
so hungry
fast my mouth is watering all of it all
of it
there you go i'll be your sushi making a
mess please
is that what this is oh yes yeah okay
we're in trouble if you don't know what
an egg is
yeah yeah now we're going to add these
three
[Laughter]
weight sauces before greens okay okay
sauces
as much sauce as you'd like yes yes what
is the purpley one
the purple one this is a blueberry
habanero salsa
this is
this looks my mouth is watering i'm so
happy this is
the cilantro onions don't touch your
eyes
that's all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can you imagine them as children at one
school
look at south space he loves it i love
mine i love mike
mine is so good i look like i need an
alabama i need a burrito from the side
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going